after the closing bell on february 1st
2022 paypal cfo john rainey forecasted
that due to a variety of hurdles and
challenges investors should be more
cautious about the short-term future of
paypal usually such an announcement may
cause a five or seven percent decline
after hours but paypal stock tumbled 18
after hours
at this point executives and investors
likely hope that a new trading day would
be much kinder to paypal and that the
fear would subside but on february 2nd
losses just continued to compound and
paypal would end up posting their worst
trading day ever losing a painful 24
since then paypal has continued to bleed
falling a total of 30 percent
now this decline itself would be
considered a bear market given that the
sell-off is more than 20
but this is just the most recent of
paypal's losses since the end of july
paypal stock has crashed a total of 60
percent which correlates to over a 200
billion loss in market cap clearly
paypal stock is experiencing a mini
depression so what happened to paypal
taking a look back one of paypal's
biggest shortfalls was that they were
never able to achieve a sustainable
operation by themselves like many
startups paypal had a rough time turning
a profit in the early days
but despite their lack of profitability
they did have millions of customers
thanks to the rapid adoption of the
internet focusing on customers as
opposed to profits was perfectly fine
throughout the late 1990s as it was
pretty easy to source funding especially
for a rapidly growing fintech company
but all of this would change at the turn
of the millennium with the burst of the
dotcom bubble by 2001 it was clear that
paypal needed to focus on profitability
if they wanted to survive but their ceo
elon musk seemed to be distracted
elon wanted to grow paypal into a
comprehensive financial platform and
transition their servers from linux to
microsoft while these ambitions may have
been best for the company long term the
other executives felt that elon was
forgetting about the main priority which
was turning a profit so while elon was
on vacation they decided to go ahead and
fire him and peter thiel would take over
this shifted the company's focus in the
right direction but they still had a
long way to go
ebay had announced the partnership with
wells fargo to launch their own in-house
payment system called the bill point and
given that 61 of paypal's revenue came
from ebay this was not good by any means
in fact this extreme dependence on ebay
was the primary reason that both google
and yahoo refused to acquire paypal the
only company willing to acquire paypal
was ebay but they had a pretty predatory
offer they offered 400 million dollars
and said quote we are going to make this
offer once and then crush you you should
really take this offer considering this
peter decided to throw a hail mary by
taking paypal public in february of
2002. just a few years before this this
would have been easy money but this was
at the peak of the dotcom crash so
investors were extremely conservative
nonetheless the ipo valued paypal at 1.2
billion dollars which just goes to show
how predatory ebay's initial offer was
seeing this ebay realized that they had
lost the bidding war but they didn't
want to also lose paypal so they offered
a much more reasonable 1.5 billion
dollars and given the poor financial
state of paypal peter decided to simply
give in and sell the company peter had
successfully defended paypal from a
predatory acquisition but he didn't save
paypal from their dependency issue and
now that ebay had control of paypal this
dependency would just get worse over the
next decade
even though the acquisition was breeding
an unhealthy dependency on ebay the
acquisition was quite beneficial in the
short term ebay basically eliminated
paypal's profitability issues overnight
as they were comfortably able to absorb
their losses similarly now that paypal
and ebay were no longer competitors
there were no threats of ebay dropping
support for paypal so paypal could just
focus on growth once again and this was
relatively simple as well they basically
had the entire ebay marketplace to go
after but at the same time this heavily
limited their potential a perfect
example of this is the explosive rise of
venmo venmo wasn't founded till 2009 or
over a decade after paypal yet they
dominate the peer-to-peer market today
in fact venmo is so popular that venmo
has become a verb like google another
great example of paypal stagnation was
square square was founded in 2009 as a
simple financial services company yet
they're worth 60 billion dollars by
themselves today in both of these cases
you would think that paypal had a
massive advantage and that they would
have crushed van moa and square but
under ebay that wasn't really possible
now this isn't to say that paypal was
doing bad they were rapidly growing in
ebay's bubble surpassing 100 million
active users in 2011. so paypal
stagnation was more of a lack of
expansion as opposed to a lack of growth
in their own niche such expansion
efforts were the key to evolving into a
diversified financial services business
but instead paypal was stuck under the
golden chains of ebay but paypal wasn't
the only one that was being hindered by
the other
you see it it wasn't that beneficial for
ebay to keep paypal around either
because there wasn't much synergy
between the two companies sure paypal
gave ebay control over payments on the
platform but to get this control ebay
had to support paypal in their
non-ebay-related business endeavors as
well in 2013 for example paypal realized
that they were losing in the
peer-to-peer market so they decided to
acquire braintree or venmo for 800
million dollars this was a great
acquisition for paypal but guess who had
to pay the bill
now it's not like ebay didn't want
paypal to succeed it's just that they
didn't have very much in common for a
partnership to work you need to be able
to share resources and to minimize costs
for example facebook already had a bunch
of app developers and social media
experts on board when they bought
instagram so the companies could easily
share resources but it's not like ebay
just had a bunch of financial analysts
and credit card experts laying around
so from ebay's perspective it felt like
they had the burden of running a whole
other company when all they wanted was
an integrated payment platform and with
time it became more and more clear that
it was best for both companies if the
duo split ways
in late 2014 ebay announced that they
would be spinning off paypal into their
own business once again
the plan was to take the company public
on the nasdaq and ebay investors would
get one share of paypal for every share
of ebay they owned
aside from this ebay announced that they
would continue working with paypal up
until 2020 at which point they'll switch
over to addient for payment processing
however they also said that they will
support paypal as an option up until
july of 2023 so paypal had plenty of
time to grow their business outside of
ebay and this time it was much easier
than their attempt in the early 2000s
paypal was an established and trusted
brand now which made it much easier for
them to garner new online merchants
on top of this paypal was finally
profitable as well so they didn't have
to constantly worry about raising more
capital
instead they could use their profits to
buy out other companies and that's
exactly what they did since 2016 paypal
has completed a total of 12 acquisitions
with the most famous ones being isettle
and honey
it wasn't all smooth though right before
paypal broke off from ebay in mid-2015
their draft terms of service got leaked
and one portion of their tus especially
caught people's attention the tos
outlined that paypal had the right to
robot caller and autotext users at will
and if customers didn't agree to this
they were forced to shut down their
accounts
to make things worse paypal had to just
pay 25 million in clients regarding
deceptive business practices so the last
thing they needed right before their ipo
was another pr nightmare nonetheless
paypal did end up working through these
issues and over the next couple of years
they were able to double their annual
income from about 1 billion dollars to 2
billion
but their real growth didn't come around
until 2020 when the pandemic came around
as you would guess when people were
locked at home they were much more
likely to use online-based financial
services as opposed to traditional
financial services people were also
spending much more money online which
just further accelerated paypal's growth
despite all this growth though
expectations were even higher and paypal
was soon not able to live up to the hype
as soon as the pandemic hit investors
flocked towards technology stocks they
dumped their positions in airlines
restaurants and hotels and all this
money flooded into tech this led to one
of the most explosive runs in paypal's
history from their pandemic low paypal
rocketed 244 within the next 12 months
this translated to a 760 return since
ipo or an 8.6x return but the problem
was that paypal's bottom line had only
grown about 5x which meant that paypal
was relatively overvalued by 72 percent
compared to their ipo valuation to make
things worse paypal's net income was
beginning to stagnate at about 5 billion
and as investors started to realize that
maybe they gave paypal a bit too much
credit and that the stock was relatively
overvalued they started to sell this
sell-off didn't just affect paypal
either investors had bid up all state
home stocks beyond belief and now they
were taking profits left and right by
the start of 2022 paypal stock was
already down about 40
and the poor guidance was the nil in the
coffin looking back though paypal's
tumultuous history was never their fault
it was almost always due to their
circumstances initially paypal struggled
to stay afloat in the funding drought
that followed the dot-com bubble this
forced them to join ebay which largely
limited them into ebay's marketplace
bubble for over a decade after they
finally spun off from ebay they had to
spend years diversifying and building a
business that didn't solely depend on
ebay and just as they escaped ebay's
golden chains they got caught up in the
tech run-up that followed the covert
crash but despite all these setbacks and
hurdles one thing that has remained
constant is paypal's resilience and i
don't think that's changed in fact i
think a lot of investors are sleeping on
paypal right now
just a couple of months ago paypal
announced that amazon would start
accepting venmo in 2022 now personally i
don't think anybody should be using
venmo to pay for goods on amazon when
they could be earning cashback or
rewards using credit cards but
regardless of what i think or what is
the smartest financial decision i'm sure
there's going to be loads of people
using venmo on amazon and even if paypal
only captures a couple of percent of
amazon's marketplace we're talking about
tens of billions of dollars worth of
transactions every year on top of this i
think it's highly likely that people who
got used to paypal services during the
pandemic will just continue to use their
services more after the pandemic
whenever that is so i think it's just a
matter of time until paypal switches
this year or two of stagnation into a
decade of growth but that's just what i
think and it's not financial advice do
you guys use paypal and if so what do
you use it for comment that down below
also drop a like if you think paypal's
recovery is inevitable and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one